[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau rendez-vous
que nous faisons depuis quelques temps
qui est en rendez-vous photo avec notre
monsieur photo Claude chose bonjour
bonjour Patrice vous allez bien alors
vous allez nous nous parler de
d'exposition i vous avez vu
d'expositions à venir de plein de de
choses qui intéressent évidemment les
amateurs de photos et puis vous nous
avez amener si je peux dire un invité
qu'on est ravi de recevoir qui est
Philippe mecller bonjour bonjour alors
dans dans dans le civil dans la vie vous
êtes médecin vous êtes chger
obstétricien à parli 2 c'est ça
absolument euh donc voilà vous faites
c'est grâce à vous que naissent beaucoup
d'enfants même si la natalité baisse un
peu en ce moment oui absolument
absolument puis vous avez une passion
qui est la photo h depuis depuis
toujours bah depuis toujours parce que
j'ai commencé avec les caméras par
exemple pour la vidéo les Super 8 quand
j'étais petit en vacances avec mes
parents et puis la photo et puis et puis
l'évolution technique et puis c'est un
hobby que j'ai la chance de pouvoir
voyager et et de pouvoir faire ben un
peu de passion et que je partage à la
fois sur Internet et auprès de gens
voilà voilà et alors et il y a une
particularité dans votre façon de de
prendre des photos vous disiez justement
il y a les technologies les technologies
nouvelles et vous utilisez beaucoup le
drone voilà en
2013 il y a une marque française qui a
sorti un drone qui s'appelait le bibop
qui était assez intéressant mais qui
m'avait pas totalement convaincu dans
l'idée et est sortie une marque chinoise
qui a commencé son premier drone qui a
eu beaucoup de succès et c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé le drone en pour
associer aux vidéos au sol une dizaine
d'années donc oui il y a exactement 10
ans la marque a sorti le premier drone
obist pour hobbyist pour amateurs et
depuis ils en sont à je sais pas si une
dizaine de modèles au moins toujours à
version amateur et on se rapproche de
qualité professionnelle au niveau des
images h et j'essaie d'associer dans mes
voyages des vidéos avec les vidéos au
sol et les vidéos drone qui euh don
incroable absolument il y a il y a
est-ce qu'il y a besoin d'autorisation
quand on quand on photographie alors bah
euh l'anecdote c'est que le premier
drone en 2013 je l'ai utilisé en Islande
et j'ai été le premier droniste amateur
en Islande avec ce drone euh à
l'aéroport il savaiit pas du tout ce que
c'était j'ouvrais euh la valise avec le
drone il savait pas du tout ce que
c'était et quand je suis retourné en
Islande quelques années plus tard
maintenant il y a des petits panneaux
euh nos drones et donc selon les
pays interdit et donc il y a beaucoup de
pays où il y a une réglementation qui
s'est nettement renforcé en Europe aussi
puisqu'il y a une réglementation
européenne aujourd'hui et donc il faut
vraiment se renseigner beaucoup sur les
endroit où on va pour savoir si on va
pouvoir l'utiliser ou pas je allé au
Botswana il y a longtemps et les drones
était pas forcément permis parce qu'à
cause des braconneurs il les utilisait
pour repérer les animaux je l' utilisé
aujourd'hui c'est interdit et cetera et
cetera donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
pays interdit pardon hein mais on peut
presque violer le droit à l'image des
gens mais ça n'arrête pas on voit ça sur
internet ça n'arrête pas ça n'arrête pas
ça n'arrête pas et donc c'est moi je
suis pas là pour réglementer moi
j'essaie de respecter la réglementation
respectez la réglementation mais je veux
dire c'est vrai que voilà il faut
peut-être des autorisations de temps en
temps oui à Madagascar il faut une
autorisation on cont le le service
aérien de Madagascar qui vous envoie ou
pas une autorisation et beaucoup de pays
sont comme ça et en France et ben en
France c'est exactement la même chose il
faut alors il y a une réglementation
européenne donc qui s'applique à la
France maintenant et qui permet dans
certaines zon on a des cartes où il y a
des zones où on pourrait faire du drone
et évidemment il y a beaucoup de zones
en rouge où on n pas le droit sauf
autorisation si je veux le le château de
Versailles qui a beaucoup photographié
Claude si on faire des photos de de
alors c'est évidemment interdit d'abord
on est très proche de Paris on est dans
l'alignement de d'aérodromeord ah oui
oui il y a ça aussi euh il y a une
protection par Versailles moi j'ai
demandé une autorisation au château de
Versailles pour le faire parce que
j'avais une idée de faire une vidéo 4
saison sur versaill à l'intérieur du
château dans les jardins qui m'a été
refusé
et forcément il y a une réglementation
donc il y en a qui se sont fait piéger
il y en a qui se sont fait piéger à
Paris en faisant un drone autour de la
Tour Effel oui il y av même je crois
qu'il y a eu un procès au moment de de
du confinement euh je crois qu' il y
avait un photographe qui avait
photographié alors je crois par drone
notamment Paris désert ouiidment alors a
priori on avait pas le droit de sortir à
ce momentl ouais on a vu ça aussi au
14ou je crois qu'il y a eu un procès
qu'il a je crois qu'il a perdu je crois
ce procès oui puis il y a eu des par
exemple au feu d'artifice du 14 juillet
vous mettez un peu loin vous montez
votre drone de votre balcon je crois que
c'est Thierry Boué si ça vous dit
quelque chose non ça me dit pas grand
chose mais voilà ENF bon bref je suis
surpris par ta la réglementation que tu
évoques Philippe euh j'ai un ami qui
fait du parapente à moteur et qui fait
des photos il semblerait que lui il en
fasse plus facilement si tu veux donc
oui mais c'est pas par
décl mais c'est pas la c'est pas la même
réglementation pere pas la même
réglementation oui le drone a a une
réglementation un peu particulière alors
alors lui je sais qu'il a été accueilli
il a fait de du parpport à moteur sur le
plateau de toussul noble et quand il
s'est posé il a été arrêté par la
gendarmerie et ben ça s'appelle j'ai le
droit pas dro à cause du parapente et à
cause de la photo qu'il qu' a fa alors
voilà pardon on a on a parlé de la
réglementation mais il faut qu'on parle
maintenant de photos et des photos de de
de Philippe MeCl pourquoi de drone
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui t'a attiré dans
pe nous d'emblé quand je faisais des
vidéo au début c'était super 8 j'étais
enfant ensuite c'était H 8 ensuite
c'était 8 mm enfin ça là aussi les
camescopes se sont améliorés aujourd'hui
j'ai un camescope 4K évidemment la
qualité est presque est identique au
drone parce que il y a un photographe
célèbre hein qui faisait de
l'hélicoptère et qui a fait la Terre vue
du ciel absolument Artus Bertrand voilà
je voulais pas le nommer mais évidemment
il est archi connu et on le même
reproché parce qu'on disait voilà vous
êtes écologiste et oui c'est ça des
photoshécop c'est un reproche récent et
il s'est mis au drone il est devenu
d'ailleurs ambassadeur pour la marque
c'est vrai que c'est l'un des premiers à
avoir photographié du ciel au fond euh
hein il y avait la France vue du ciel
notamment enfin
qui livre voilà absolument et donc euh
bah on se rapproche énormément de de ce
qu'il faisait voir égal réellement dans
la mesure où si on voyage dans des
endroits assez extraordinaires qui
sortent de l'ordinaire on voit des
choses spectaculaires V du ciel alors
voilà je peux pas dire autrement c'est
ça qui m'a attiré et c'est vrai alors là
là c'est peut-être qu'on peut commenter
un peu les les les photos qu'on voit
alors ça c'est au Botswana et à l'époque
la marque de drone n'avait pas ce qu'on
appelle une caméra propriétaire et donc
on on mettait une caméra de marque GoPro
qu'on mettait au voilà sur le drone le
problème de l'époque cette caméra
maintenant les drones se vendent avec
l'appareil Absolum absolument et donc là
on tombe sur une qualité sur le film de
Madagascar sur une qualité je
dirais en tout cas techniquement
professionnelle après chacun juge ça
c'est au sol donc c'est pas le drone ça
c'est au sol dans dans les for mais
c'est l'association des deux qui me plaî
absolument c'est l'association des deux
qui me plaît et c'est vrai que quand on
arrive à avoir une caméra 4K vraiment
toute petite voilà c'est on arrive à
faire ça on est super heureux il y a eu
une exposition très récemment à la ferme
du
Mané tout à côté d'ici et et il y
avait exposant qui faisait des qui
faisait du drone justement des photos en
drone et c'était incroyable cétait dire
que tout le monde pensait d'ailleurs que
c'était des tableaux qu'il avait fait
parce qu'on voit
euh j'ai dit d'ailleurs des petit c'est
pas en drone c'était avec un ULM pardon
ce qui est un peu différent et et alors
ça faisait des les gens pensaient que
c'était des tableaux c'està dire que
vous avez des taches vertes tout d'un
coup qui arrivent dans la nature et et
qui qui sont absolument comme si c'était
un tableau qu'on avait composé alors que
c'est la réalité de la nature est-ce que
c'est le le vécu que vous avez vous
aussi absolument alors j'ai une banque
de photos importantes et dans les vidéos
on les voit aussi moi ce que j'aime bien
c'est le graphisme donc je compose ma
photo ù je compose ma je compose ma
vidéo c'est-à-dire quand je regarde
puisque j'ai le retour vidéo quand je
regarde et que je fais cette vidéo là je
la compose les îles ferroé et donc c'est
vert fé non un peu non hein c'est c'est
vert non oui c'est vert c'est non c'est
vert mais c'est sévère aussi ah c'est
sévère pour d'autres choses oui là c'est
absolument magnifique c'est le lac
baical et euh ah oui vous voyagez
énormément ouais voilà et donc ça c'est
au mois de février le lac est gelé on
est dessus et c'était un voyage
magnifique vraiment magnifique et là on
voit le lac bical alors lac baical est
près de la frontière
mongole le sudest est de de la Russie
Russie oui et là on voit ce qu'on
pourrait pas faire avec une caméra le
drone
vole je voilà là on sait maintenant on
sait là que c'est c'est une vidéo drone
et cetera mais si on s'arrêtait si on
figeait on pourrait croire que c'est
quelque chose de composé quoi
de très étonnant en vidéo on compose on
compose son image comme on compose en
photo sinon on fait n'importe quoi bon
après c'est en toute humidité je dis ça
mais et alors
pardon question de béocien mais votre
votre drone part dans le ciel si je veux
dire vous vous êtes loin oui je peux
aller à quelqu quelques kilomètres
éventuellement mais vous avez la vision
de ce que voit le drone oui j'ai le
retour vidéo en en haute définition
d'accord ça c'est les derniers hein
c'est les plus récents oui oui c'est ça
parce que autrefois voilà les drones y
allent il prenaient enfin P premier le
premier celui en Islande le premier
j'avais pas de retour vidéo je regardais
le drone et j'imaginais qu'il filmait
donc la vidéo est pas terrible mais
c'était la
première et ça c'est burningman faudrait
quand même qu'on demande l'autorisation
et que par exemple de de filmer je sais
pas 51 en drone ça serait ça serait
magnifique alors moi j'ai une licence
professionnelle he que j'utilise pas
parce que c'est je l'ai fait pour moi la
licence pro mais je et la Licence Pro
permet quoi bah permet de demander des
autorisations à la préfecture et CER et
travailler pour quelqu'un d'accord alors
là commentez-nous parce qu'on voit voilà
des images alors ça c'est Burning Man
c'est un événement qui a lieu depuis
plus de 30 ans dans le désert du
Nevada ça c'est une statue chinoise et
on voit que le drone donne des images là
c'est au drone he c'est au drone c'est
absolument incroyable là c'est donc
c'est des éléments artistiques qui sont
voilà là on dira un bé quoi enfin c'est
ah c'est
beau voilà ça c'est des marionnettes
géantes fait par un artiste espagnol et
et le drone permet d'avoir des visions
encore une fois et des cadrages qui
permett pour pas qui vous donne une une
vie une vue évidemment qu'on Pasir et
c'est ce que tu recherches dans cette
dans ces vidéos donc quelque chose qui
vraiment sort de l'ordinaire je vais
dire quelque chose de très basique
j'espère que les gens disent waouou en
les regardant un petit peu waouou un
petit
waou W regardez ça c'est quoi et ben
c'est Burning Man la nuit le jour où on
brûle le MAN le fameux hom brûle he
c'est ça exactement le samedi soir et
donc la nuit on voyait toutes ces
personnes et toutes les lumières c'est
absolument magnifique donc cet événement
il est incroyable cette année il y a eu
un vrai problème puce qu'il a plu ils
étaient tous dans la boue avait un roman
d'Amélie Auton qui était qui était sur
ce sur ce festival quelqu'un qui se
rendait à ce festival c'est possible
possible je peux pas le dire je peux pas
le confirmer mais ouais c'est ça vous
rend pas un peu jaloux euh non non pas
du tout vous n'aimez pas du tout ce que
fait
Philippe
je je vous dis j'ai pas dit que je
n'aimais pas mais c'est pas mon truc moi
mon truc c'est me balader dans Paris ou
ailleurs avec c'est bien mais c'est vrai
que mais j'apprécie les les les les
images que nous a présenté et puis parce
que je connais quand même bien Philippe
donc j'apprécie ce qu'il montre et et
c'est bien construit quoi donc je trouve
que c'est très intéressant moi de de
voir ça c'est un autre regard autre
regard c'est un regard qu'on enfin qu'on
peut pas avoir de de de hauteur d'homme
voilà c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on voit autre chose
enfin c'est et on voit autrement moi il
y a un élément qui est fondamental c'est
comme l'informatique c'est que
maintenant on a la portée de l'amateur
des outils qui sont quasiment
professionnels on a voulu m'acheter des
séquences pour la télévision et cetera
parce que on arrive à des définitions
qui permettent l'utilisation dans des
médias et on m'a voulu m'acheter on m'a
acheté d'ailleurs là où on est là par
exemple là on est dans le désert
d'atakama au euh au Chili et là c'est le
la Laguna Colorada en Bolivie c'est
magnifique ça et donc là quand on est
c'est vrai que ça vous pouvez pas
pourriez l'avoir de dessous alors ça
c'est le Salard de uni le plus grand
désert de sel du monde vous êtes très
attiré par les déserts par par des
choses nouvelles j'ai la chance de
voyager avec ma femme et il est où ce
plus grand désert euh au en Bolivie en
Bolivie en Bolivie et là vous reconnais
vraiment les images de Toscane avec la
beauté de la lumière to scan absolument
oui cette lumière qui regardez cette
composition voilà SS ont figé là comme
ça on pourrait dire tiens c'est un
tableau c'est ENF ouais bah c'est c'est
c'est une peinture ENF c'est un peu
l'idée c'est un peu l'idée la
composition je pense que Claude sera
d'accord la photo elle se fait aussi
avec une idée de composition l'image
ouais fais de la photo puisqu'on se
connaît au club photo euh et voilà donc
et là vous donc ça veut dire que vous
décider au moment précis où la vous avez
la la la vue de ce que sera la photo
voilà d'appuyer de enfin de filmer de ou
alors vous montez après ah je monte
après c'estd que là j'ai des rushes de
plusieurs heures voilà vous avez des
rushes he c'est ça voilà et je monte et
je monte et je choisis surtout la
musique là on l'entend pas mais moi ma
grande passion c'est aussi la musique et
c'est donc de synchroniser sur des
musiques euh quel genre de musique tout
types de musique Burning Man c'était des
musiques un peu de DJ parce que c'est
très c'est très rythmé le dernier film à
sokotra qui est une île yeménite où je
suis allé l'année dernière j'ai utilisé
Carl ORF carmina bin c'est c'est c'est
fabuleux ça voilà donc j'essaye la
Toscane j'avais la 7e symphonie de betov
la marche funèbre et ça marche très bien
et voilà et ça j'aime beaucoup est-ce
qu'on peut voir vos créations quelque
part bah j'ai un blog où je partage et
sur le blog je m'astreint aussi c'est
pas je m'astrein ça me plaît beaucoup
j'écris aussi sur le pays sur l'endroit
j'explique l'histoire il y a les photos
les vidéos des photos illustres il y a
un texte a il y a beaucoup de textes qui
permet de comprendre je suis allé en
Ukraine 4 mois avant la guerre avec ma
femme euh on est all à ternobyl on a
j'ai fait du drone à ternoby il faut un
permis et là c'est là vous a permis oui
il y a un permis à acheter voilà à
l'époque alors l'Ukraine par exemple
c'était d'une liberté totale on pouvait
filmer à l'intérieur de Kief ce que j'ai
fait sans aucune autorisation c'est
l'Ukraine n'est pas la Russie hein on
est d'accord on est d'accord et euh non
je veux dire qu'en Russie probablement
ça vous aurait eu plus de mal euh bah je
l'aurais pas fait mais par exemple à
Irkoutsk qui est donc la la grande ville
à côté du lac baical ben on peut on on
peut filmer bon voilà après faut pas les
choses sensibles hein comme en France
bien sûr là c'est Socotra au
Yémen un endroit incroyable c'est une
île incroyable non touristique du Toutin
il y a qu'un vol par semaine qui part
d'Abu Dhabi c'est juste hallucinant quoi
que je suis pas yanartus Bertrand mais
la vidéo parce que le Yémen au MO
detembre de l'année dernière alors l'île
yéménite de sookotra n'est pas touché
par le conflit même si les socoteries
voilà il prennent partie quand même et
là
c'était à kif il y a une grande
population dans cette île non il y a
très peu de gens ils ont pas
d'électricité quasiment enfin c'est
terrible d'cord Senia c'est en
Norvège et encore une fois c'est des
voilà on essae la composition il manque
la musique là mais c'est la musique qui
le blog s'appelle comment F of
drones comme Philippe en un seul mot pH
en pheld ofdrones.com il suffit de
taper Philippe meclire d'accord voilà là
c'est le volcan en Islande m I c l voilà
le volcan en Islande en là bravo écoutez
très alors si vous me permettez hier
soir j'ai regardé des racines et des
ailes il y avait un photographe qui
photographier les toit de Paris je sais
pas si vous avez vu c'est et j'ai pensé
à Philippe en me disant mais pourquoi il
utilise pas le drone après tout parce
que ça serait bien plus facile le gars
il montait sur le toit arnachait attaché
bien sûr parce que il fallait mais je
crois parce qu' y des difficultés à
utiliser le
droneou c'est ça Paris n'a pas le droit
d'être survolé on en princip par les av
sauf par desraacinés des ailes oui c'est
ça on est la télévision française voilà
on a des droits que le hobbyist n le
fameux Baron Noir je ne sais pas si
vousz passous l'AR de triom qui était
recherché pendant des années ben merci
beaucoup bra donc je pense que tu nous
as parlé globalement de ton donc que la
photo au drone où on peut la pratiquer
donc partout en demandant des
autorisations euh comment tu as comment
tu es venu tu nous as expliqué donc ton
ton ton cheminement et puis qu'est-ce
qu'apporte la photo de drone mais
effectivement à travers tes images nous
avons vu que tu que qu'il apporte un
regard complètement différento voilà
c'est ça différ alors Claude on va
passer bah à l'actualité de la photo
alors une actualité passée d'abord mais
d'exposition importantes que vous avez
vu et et de nous dire ce que vous en
avez retenu c'est il y a il y a d'abord
les les Rencontres d'Arles donc les
Rencontres d'Arles qui se sont déroulé à
partir du début juillet jusà SEP alors
moi j'y vais en principe sur la première
semaine puisque la première
semaine Patrick Patrice vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui viennent et surtout
les photographes qui viennent présenter
leur travail leur travail donc voilà
alors ça c'est le le c'était vous voyez
fond AR il y avait siège de la nouvelle
fondation VO la Fondation Luma si vous
voulez qui est qui est comment s'appelle
faite par Madame madame Hofman la
propriétaire du laboratoire du même nom
alors j'ai dans cette présentation bon
d'ailleurs et donc sur cette première
semain c'est le même architecte que la
Fondation von voilà c'est ça quoi Fran
Guer Fran Guer donc j'ai essayé de faire
pour présenter puisque c'est une
exposition passée un
de ce que j'ai vu et ce que j'ai
remarqué ça c'est la madame c'était une
photo de
Booba leilla si vous voulez qui une très
très belle Booba c'est pas le rappeur
non non non Booba Booba B u T b a T donc
alors il y avait plusieurs expositions
il y avait plusieurs expositions donc
que j'estime des expositions de prestige
comme Dian Arbus qui était présenté donc
à la Fondation l'umain il y avait 453
photos de Dian Arbus c'était dans
présenté dans un une salle recouverte de
miroir pour les pour les les gens qui
connaissent pas Dian Arbus Dian Arbus
c'est une photographe américaine qui est
qui a vécu dans la première partie du du
20e siècle et qui est décédée aux
environs de de 2000 quelque chose comme
ça donc je me souviens plus la date
désolé mais il y avait aussi un autre
photographe qui
était s later alors certainement certain
certains de nos
des téléspectateurs connaîtront c'est un
monsieur qui a photog il y a une photo
très emblématique de lui de une photo
dans un bar et il a photographier
l'extérieur avec l'appui sur les vitres
et donc mais moi j'ai découvert dans
cette dans cette exposition aussi des
photos de il a fait des photos de nu qui
étaient d'une sensualité d'une
sensibilité extrême ça c'est lui comment
non ça c'est pas ça non donc euh euh
c'est CIT c'était vraiment quelque chose
de très très beau si tu veux à voir et
puis il y avait les beau et miens aussi
une série de photos il y avait des
photos d'un de plusieurs photographes
qui ont pris des photos à Sa Sainte
Marie de la Mer donc voilà comm on peut
voir c'est étéit assez étonnant moi j'ai
trouveré ça quand même très très beau si
donc si vous voulez c'est pour moi je
dirais que har 2023 c'était un bon cru
donc il y avait il y avait des choses
qui des annéesù vous étiez plus déçu les
années surtout en 20020 21 c'était suite
à la fin du
covid c'était c'était différent mais ça
relève le niveau alors comment va
évoluer AR c'est c'est des grandes
questions qu'on peut se poser mais on s
que ça devient quand même un rendez-vous
de plus en plus incontourable ça fa plus
4S ça existe mais là je veux dire tout
le monde parle aujourd'hui de des
rencontres d'arleo
ENF ouisolument donc et puis la
Fondation l prend beaucoup de plus en
plus puisque elle a racheté tout le parc
des des des des des réparations SNCF et
donc il y avait alors il y a une photo
que que j'ai vu là où un monsieur
regarde un cornet et quand j'ai fait
cette photo c'est c'est un ami qui était
à côté donc j'ai photographié ça me
rappelait présume que vous connaissez
Jean de la lune cette pièce avec comment
il s'appelle Jean-Louis Barot qui
regarde à travers et donc c'est c'est un
peu cette similitude et et cet ami m'a
donné l'autorisation de de publier cette
cette quoi donc parce que il faut
demander quand même les
autorisationsou c'est comme avec le
drone comme avec le drone voilà cette
photo moi je trouve que ça c'est une
photo de vous ah c'est une photo de moi
avec un ami qui
pose bravo c'est très joli donc et quand
vous voyez j'ai fait la photo j'ai pensé
à cette photo de Jean-Louis barreau
habillé en Pier qui regarde une lunette
d'accord dans le fil c'est un film je
crois gen de la lune quelque che c'est
une pièce un film ouais
donc alors autre exposition alors à
Paris qui était importante alors voilà
pendant cette période de l'été il y a eu
quand même de belles expositions à Paris
il y a il y a eu entre autres Harry
Guillard qui est un photographe belge
qui vit toujours qui a exposé au bal à
côté de la la place de Clichy mais ça
c'est lui c'est des photos qui sont
peut-être anciennes mais la scénographie
la mise en scène était extraordinaire
donc j'ai tenu à présenter ce ce travail
là parce que malheureusement c'est passé
passé et puis il y a eu pas mal pas mal
de choses aussi il y avait il y a eu
beaucoup d'expositions et il y a eu
entre autres l'exposition qui a démarré
cet été à boubour qui est le le cour à
cours alors attendez alors là voilà ça
c'était les cétait passé c'était les
photos passé maintenant on va on va
parler de ce qu'on peut voir voilà alors
il y a d'abord peut-être le le la barge
le qu de la photo oui alors c'est une
racontez-nous ça c'estè c'est en face de
la
bi voilà c'est vous descendez le métro
c'est qui de la gare c'est juste à côté
et c'est quelque chose qui est c'est
constant enfin c'est récurrent voilà
c'est ça c'est voilà c'est une barche
dans lequel on peut prendre un verre et
c'est très agréable puisque vous êtes
sur les qu de scè ah c'est bien à côté
de la scène s'il pleut vous pouvez
prendre le verre à l'intérieur et on
peut aussi déjeuner donc voilà vous avez
la photo de un restaurant et expo photo
c'est et donc dans le le dans la cale il
y a une expo photo et là quand j'y suis
allé j'y suis allé plusieurs fois entre
autres il y avait Martine par j'ai voulu
montrer Martine par parce que c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui est assez
ironique sur le la façon de se
comportent les touristes britanque avit
déjà parlé d'ailleurs ici mais mais
c'est vrai que c'est c'est très drôle
c'est très drôle et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut absolument voir
parce que c'est ouvert on peut y aller
qu sur la barge ououi je suis allé je
suis allé à l'expo Martine par et c'est
vrai que avec une conférencière qui
était très bien et
qui des conférencières qui fait
régulièrement gratuitement d'ailleurs
grat ou c'est gratuit ah c'est ça on
boit un coup quoi enfin ver on apprend
quelque chose on apprend des ch ch c'est
bien oui en plus des conférenciers et à
l'heure actuelle il y a des images de de
la FP d'accord l'Agence France Press et
il y a des choses quand même qui
sont tous les mois il y a une exposition
qui qui est présentée il y a un
renouveau donc c'est quelque chose
vraiment très très intéressant alors
vous vouliez nous conduire à beauourg
allons-y voilà euh alors c'est c'est un
grand euh grand producteur de de cinéma
qui s'appelle marine carpit c'est ça oui
c'est çaose c'est il y a aussi les
collections de B collections et plus les
collections de beauourg et il y a les
collections de beauourg et c'est
l'exposition s'appelle corps à corore
c'est sur l'histoire de la photo c'est
jusque toute la période avant que arrive
la il y a quelques photos en couleur
mais c'est essentiellement noir blanc
mais il y a entre autres une photo qui
est assez remarquable c'est c'est le
portrait de doramar ah oui et par qui
par Picasso non non non non non non non
pas il preneait pas de photo Picasso non
non non il peignait mais c'était
vraiment c'est mais je dis ça parce
qu'ou portrait de Rabar par c'est c'est
magnifique magnifique c'est puis il y a
beaucoup de photos donc c'est les
collections ça part depuis le début donc
on voit les premiers tirages argentiques
et cette exposition est
essentiellement orienté vers
l'argentique et il y a des choses qui
sont vraiment extraordinaires donc ils
veulent pas qu'on prenne de photos quand
même dedans mais j' pr prendre les
photos des photos voilà c'est ça mais
j'en ai pris quelqu allez vous
conseillez ça alleer à beauour il faut
aller voir ça je crois l'exposition
n'est pas donnée mais il faut aller voir
c'est en plus on a la chance de monter
au dernier étage de beauourg qui nous
amène vers au-dessus des toit de Paris
et ça c'est et ça c'est mag je présume
que vous connaissez oui donc voilà c'est
donc je c'est vrai qu'on peut conseiller
à tout le monde d'aller à Bourg c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs c'est très amusant
parce qu'il y eu cette polémique sur
beauourg pendant la construction plus
personne ça ne choque absolument plus
personne et c'est vrai que de
l'intérieur quoi qu'on pense de boubour
c'est fabuleux mais donc euh alors après
on passe à iring Pen Irwing Pen alors
moi c'est c'est certainement je pense
que Philippe connaît aussi Erwin Pen
c'est c'est quand même tous les
photographes je pense connaissent i je
suis allé à l'expo et vous y êtes àex et
alors ça vaut le coup ah ben c'est enfin
c'est il est humoristique et puis il y a
une vidéo où il parle et c'est
extraordinaire enfin c'est des gens qui
don une humilité incroyable et qui
racontent leur travail c'est terrible
ouais ouais alors il c'est c'est la
galerie tadeouropak ouais qui est une
grande grand galeriste évidemment mais
en 2018 il avait exposé aussi au Grand
Palais là c'est le musée Mao hein
donc c'est au musée Mayol a wingpen ah
non
c'esten a eu il y a eu au musée de Mar
mais là c'est c'est c'est he c'est ça
oui oui c'est dans c'est dans Paris donc
c'est la rue grand galeriste grand grand
connaisseur d'Arc contemporain enfin
grand grand d' contemporain mais là
c'est oui là c'est sur la photo d'ine
Pen alors hroine Pen a fait beaucoup de
studio essentiellement même c'est nu si
vous voulez il est sorti de des des
clichés de la
femme de modèle il a pris des femmes
dites comment dire on pourrait dire je
sais pas si je peux dire normal mais il
a fait des des sujets eu un peu
Hollywood quand même non ou ouais non
non mais il avait un studio et là donc
dans cette exposition il présente des
photos qu'on avait pas vu mais enfin les
photos que vous avez passé que qu nous a
passé notre ami Xavier il y a le
portrait de Picasso moi je trouve que je
trouve ça fascinant quand on vois cette
photo ce regard profond de Picasso
Picasso on en avait déjà parlé hein ici
parce que ou euh c'est vrai que c'est
magnifique hein voilà et il y a aussi
les vrai oui oui c'est c'est de cocto il
av on avait déjà qui est passé qui est
là aussi donc dans cette dans cette
série parfait donc ça c'est cette rue de
DLEM dans le Maré hein dans dans le 3e
ouais dans une galerie qui est qui est
qui est évidemment extrêmement célèbre
celle de Tadou RAC euh après notre notre
exposition toujours bah toujours dans le
même quartier dans le même quartier si
c'est c'est là où il y a beaucoup de
galeries de galeries donc surtout photos
et puis il y en a aussi dans le dans le
10e donc c'est la galerie paulkaint Gill
et je je j'ai mis des photos de
Jacomelli c'est un photographe italien
qui est décédé en 2000 et je trouve il a
photographié donc c'est voilà le
personnagei c'est lui ouais donc il est
assez curieux comme personnage mais bon
et c'est un monsieur qui disait que la
photographie c'est d'abord d' d'acheter
des objets des optiques de très bonne
qualité pour avoir un bon résultat
photographié le boîtier il disait que
c'est pas ça et il ait c'est un point
commun avec Philippe puisque voilà mais
vous êtes vous vous êtes très sensible
au progrès technique et et la photo que
nous a montré Patrick Xavier pardon euh
c'était il a fait toute une série de
photos sur les les comment s'appelle sur
les le matériel non non non sur les les
les apprentiscurés les séminaristes ah
les séminaristes d'accord donc à Rome
c'était c'est quelque chose de très très
intéressant et puis Fontana bon c'est
une autre photo regardee ça c'est
amusant non non c'est toujours ah oui
c'est oui pardon c'est les séminaristes
en effet
c'est beau d'ailleurs sur la neige ouais
il y a toute une série mais c'est qui
est énorme c'est une photo ça c'est he
c'est on pourrait croire que c'est autre
chose qu'une photo he qu'on aurait pu
faire avec un drone d'ailleurs ou il y
av oui il y avait un côté un peu comme
ça qui qui change un peu la la
composition qui est incroyable de cette
et ben parfait et puis alors peut-être
un mot sur bah sur ce qu'on peut voir
dans on va pouvoir voir dans les
semaines qui viennent alors on arrive là
dans le la période à partir du mois de
novembre ce qu'on appelle souvent
novembre c'est le Mois de la Photo oui
où on va trouver dans Paris il y a un
parcours qui est autour de la dans le
quartier Saint-Germain sur la photo
toutes les galeries qui sont dans ce
quartier entre la rue de Seine et la rue
Mazarine on voit des des il y a des
expositions photos je il y a aussi les
rencontres photographiques dans la dans
le 10e arrondissement ça c'est un autre
arrondissement c'est un autre
arrondissement de Paris et surtout Paris
Photo et puis il y a Paris
Photo je me permettrais Grand Palais
éphémère tu es dans le Grand Palais
éphémère et je me permettrai de faire un
petit reportage pour pouvoir montrer
lors de la prochaine présentation pour
montrer donc c'est ça moi j'incite les
gens qui sont passionnés par la photo
d'aller quand même Erer dans Paris pour
oui dans dans ces galeries dans toutes
ces galeries que parce que c'est l'entr
vemb notamment voilà comment pendant le
mois de novembre notamment c'est là qu'
mais merci beaucoup écoute écoutez
Patrice voilà merci beaucoup Claude
Philippe mecller merci et encore bravo
et voilà et puis on va on va se
précipiter sur votre sur votre blog pour
vous suivre suivre voilà vosos périples
quand quand vous n'êtes pas en train
d'opérer ou de ou d'accoucher par
exemple faites pas de photos des est-ce
que par si j'ai fait des photos si je
fais des photos de femmees enceinte je
fais des photos je fais de la photo la
vraie photo noir et blanc couleur non
non je sais non non je je vous demande
ça parce que alors c'est un sujet qui
n'a rien à voir mais je sais qu'il y
avait des il y avait beaucoup de de de
pères tout ça qui
voulaient filmer l'accouchement de leurs
femmes et il y a parfois des médecins
qui lu disent écoutez on est en train de
faire un acte
médical ça dépend de quel point de vue
ils se mettent on va dire pour faire et
vous vous diriez quoi alors si on vous
demandez non mais faut qu'il se mette du
bon côté c'est faut qu'il regarde le
côté où ça soit plus joli encore une
fois c'est un de composition
ou non non mais voilà on peut
photographier que vous vous vous ne
sortez pas les photograp S si c'est
délicat je suis respectueux merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être venu merci beaucoup Claude merci
beaucoup Patrice et puis à très vite
alors on fera le point sur tout ce qui
s'est passé tout ce qui se passe au mois
de novembre voilà et je pense qu'il va
se passer beaucoup de choses donc euh
vous y serai voilà j serai et j'essaer
de faire un
montage animé et photographiqueci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Patrice et bonne
[Musique]
journée